Today's topic, Chris, Delias posted a new video. If you aren't aware.
Chris Delia got in a little situation where he took a leave of absence after
people alleged that he did some things with some, uh,
people who belonged on a playground, the best way I put, I, I don't know. I, I,
Hey, he was caught playing on the wrong playground. You know what I mean?
What I mean, he was on the swing set should have been at the swing club, a
kind of thing. Yo, you slept good today. Last time you slept good.
I'm having my Cheerios. I, I could see that you. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That cholesterol's gone.
<Laugh> okay. Hi everyone.
I know that it's been a really long time since you've heard from me. Um,
and when the news broke, um,
I put out a statement that said everything I've done has been legal and
consensual and that's true. And I wanted that statement to speak for itself.
But what I have come to understand is, um,
this was always about sex to me.
My life was, I mean, sex controlled my life.
It was my focus all the time.
And I had a problem and I do have a problem. It's not like you, you, you know,
months down the line, you just kind of, everything's better.
I need to do work on that.
When I first started doing standup and I started getting a little bit of
notoriety in my early thirties.
I want you guys to pee something very interesting. This,
he feels terrible about what he did,
but what he did was not non-consensual or not illegal. Now,
if you guys remember to the video I did. I said, what Chris did
wasn't illegal,
but it was still wrong in the sense that there was no consideration for
the Pete pulled that he was being involved with.
It was extremely selfish and was also a lack of respect towards himself.
And that's the realization that he's coming to,
which a lot of men are gonna live with. At some point,
when you are out there in these streets as a man,
this is what I said when I said there's a cost, right?
And I'm sure even for him, like if it's not, if it's not his friendships or,
you know, his relationships, it's his mental health. Like it affects you.
This is what I'm talking about.
You know, having got a lot easier is the, you know,
for the lack of better words. And I felt lucky, I felt like, oh wow,
I don't need to work as hard. You know,
I can just do a show and then have six or roll into a city
and look at my, uh, inbox and then just start writing.
And, and I did, man. I wrote, I mean,
I know you've seen some of the messages online.
I, I mean, there's, there's way more than that. I, I, I would get 50,
at least 50 messages after a show each city a night and I would reply to all of
them. And I thought in my, uh,
in my mind that being straight up with these women was the right thing to do.
I'd say, Hey, come to my hotel room and let's have, let's make out.
Let's let's do this. Let's do that. And that was what I thought was right.
I realized through all of this,
that doing that is just treating like it's casual
and, and being flippant with people.
Ain't that literally what I said, I didn't say. Right.
And I said it also last time, I said, you do a lot because you lack a lot.
Right? Your glut because of a space that you're trying to feel. Yeah,
definitely. But the truth is no matter how many ladies come through the door,
no matter how many people you enter, you're not full.
There's nothing entering inside of you. There's,
there's nothing that you're filling. Right. So there's always, or to be done.
And he said, he said that it was easier, right? Oh yes. It is easier.
Mm-hmm <affirmative>. It is. And I believe him where you receive 50 messages,
you know, I seen some of the message you received.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> I seen the message that I received.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> um, why, why do you think I don't have social media?
I know mm-hmm <affirmative> I'm on the brink. Okay. I'm on the brink. Okay.
Let me get away from all that. It's scary. Yeah. Sometimes I,
I believe in, it's scary.
It's I'm still in a mode where I'm still in a mode where I know I'm not there no
more, but I still, I still have a baggage from when I was a kid.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> right where I was a ugly kid. Correct.
I was treating the like that.
And it's always, when I see a message and everything and stuff,
if someone I do not know, right. I'm like, who sent you? Yep.
Everything is like a trap is scary.
The amount and how and what and what,
and what people are willing to do without you even ask.
And it's easy to enjoy those in that it's right there. And the thing is,
people think that once you, as to that level,
you've received some kind of God level of discipline or that you're a completely
different human being than the rest of the population.
Not realizing. Yeah.
You're just a regular person who now has all this adulation. Yeah.
There's no training. Nope. There's no information out there. No,
there's no really great tips on handle. Handle it. Nos, no seminar.
They just give you lots of money and they give you lots of followers and they
give you lots of availability and they're like, manage all this. No,
it doesn't mean that you don't have responsibility.
It doesn't mean that this is not your job to manage it.
What I'm saying is there is no training. Oh. And the thing that happened is,
and that's why I kept on saying to you, I am glad that this is happening now.
Oh, hell yeah. And now when I was 19, I'm not saying that 19 years old,
I'm talking about me at 19. I don't know y'all or none.
Y y'all be me when I was 19. I don't give a. I'm not talking about you.
This ain't about you. Right. Uh,
I'm just glad it didn't happen to me when I was 19. You understand? And, and,
and I tell you more because of,
let's say who I be became in the dance community,
the kind of fame that this happened, that this happening now,
I kind of had it in a smaller scale in the dance community,
those messages on a smaller scale,
I was receiving mm-hmm <affirmative> after let's say a big event was to move can
on leash. Whether I was participating or whether I was hosting,
I received messages. Yep. It's just that then again,
I didn't have the conf I was like on who sent you mode and you got all these
foreign people coming to town. Yep. To participate. They, and they leaving.
They might never see you. And like, they might never see they about that.
They about that life. Oh, hell yeah. And I was having a conversation with,
one of my friends were like, yo, I never heard stories about you and dancers.
Why? Like, cause there's none. There's nothing I understand right now.
We're just talking about ladies, but you could replace this with substances.
You could replace it with food, with games, you know, going to the casino poker.
Yep. Alcohol with we with, with anything. You understand what I'm saying?
You could replace this with and that's girl,
but it could be anything and it's easy. Yep. Example, you're a bartender.
You work in a bar. You are the bartender at that bar. Okay.
You flip bottles. Ladies come and see you. It's your world.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> to a smaller scale and it's your world and it's good and
become easy.
That's not the guy I want to be. It's not okay. And I'm sorry for that.
It makes me feel shameful and it makes me feel bad. You know,
people talk a lot about the power dynamic and about, uh, well,
why should someone who want, who is a fan of yours,
have to worry about if you want to sleep with them or not.
And I don't know where I fall on that. Especially in my early thirties,
I would be like, well, the, the girl has the power because that's, you know,
they, they, I want to have sex with them and,
and if they wanna have sex with me then great.
But what I can say is the familiarity that I had
with these women to have, I was like, oh, they already used me.
They already know me. I didn't have to do the extra work.
And I was talking to one of my friends about this
and about the power dynamic and about the familiarity and not having to
use that. And he, and I said, why is this, why is that behavior, uh,
not okay.
Why is it not okay to sleep with somebody if it's consensual and they wanna
sleep with you? And, and he said, it's okay.
Well, it is okay. It's okay until it's not. And that was when, you know,
a lot of it clicked for me. It was
something that just became life controlling. I mean,
I would think about it all the time. I would,
I would go and I would do my show and I, you know, like I just said earlier,
and I just, it was too much. And it, it became a,
a lifestyle that I didn't know how to stop. I didn't even think I had a problem.
I thought that this was how it was.
I thought that guys in my position were lucky enough and fortunate enough,
and it was going outta control. I never stopped it.
I cheated on most of the girls that I've been with. I cheated on my fiance now.
And this is my dream girl. This is the girl that wanna be with,
for the rest of my life. And even that wouldn't stop what I was doing.
And I was headed for a, I was headed for, you know, what I was headed for.
I was headed for this and this needed to happen because I wouldn't have stopped
cheating. I wouldn't have stopped using.
So what I told you guys, when I said, there's always a cost. There's everyone.
You're all gonna pay. Keep rolling those dices, right? It's like,
when you go to the casino, you win a few times. You're feeling good.
Keep rolling. You're going loose, cut your loses and, and walk out.
If you've made it far enough, without cake walk away,
you <affirmative> because you do not want it to come for you.
Walk away before the house makes you walk away from the table. You gotta know,
you gotta know what is what I was talking about.
When he said it just became too much. This is what I mean,
when I'm saying there's that glut and stuff.
I'm not saying this I've been through it.
So I know I've seen by homies go through it. Mm-hmm <affirmative>,
I've seen the young ladies like ask me for advice. And I'm like, bro,
this is what's going. And I also,
so this is a pattern I kid you not literally every dude who I've ever known,
who's got, you know, a body count or, you know, if they've done a lot of dirt,
they go through this process, you gotta know. Yep.
So I have a chance here to, you know, and I have been doing the work and,
and being somebody who is a role model for my son, and I want to do that.
And I can't, I, I can't stress that enough. You know,
I can't go back and I can't, I can't fix that part of me that, that,
that hole in me that was trying to be filled with that, you know,
the loneliness on the road or the, or the fear that I felt,
or the insecurity that I, you know, I would,
I would try to chase and just conquer with this, with sticks. And, and it was,
uh, it was outta control.
So I have a chance here to apologize to the people who
got caught up in that.
So some of wondering why is he apologizing? What's that apologizing for,
if you didn't do anything wrong again,
you could have done something that isn't necessarily evil and still be
incredibly selfish. You can hurt people around you with your selfishness.
And it not necessarily be a cancelable offense that needs to be in the news or
all this other stuff.
We have a problem in this country where we're teaching young men that they have
to overvalue, you know, doing a lot of stuff and sleeping with a lot of women,
right? Yeah. And that we don't teach them what the consequences are that are,
and you're watching it on a big stage. So does the old people, yes.
Mean I've owed women apologies before?
Not because something terrible ne something terrible necessarily happened,
but because I recognize that the way I engaged in my relationships and my
dynamics was selfish.
I'm talking about before I ever did any of this YouTube or online stuff.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and I'm sure you guys can also think of that someone you
dated, where you may not have been the most compassionate person,
or you may even engaged in that relationship selfishly for your own desire
either cuz it was a, you know, a rebound or someone you had no interest in,
but they showed you attention.
We could all think of situations where we weren't emotionally considerate now
is that bad? Sure. Doesn't mean that it's necessarily something that is it,
is it wrong? It needs to be on the public platform or for everyone to talk,
but should you apologize? Of course. Hmm. The way we teach men and is that we,
we value. Yep. We value body count,
but it's also taboo. So there's the aspect of valuing it.
But it's the aspect of having to lie about it.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> lie to a certain degree. Yeah. To a certain degree.
Not as I'm not saying that you have to lie, but I mean,
if you want to engage or if you want,
you have to cover some things up it's paradoxal basically. And,
and that creates even more problems thus far with everything that happened with
every people and every celebrity that happened or scandals and everything,
it was the best apology you have scene. It was not so straightforward.
But what was supposed to be said was supposed to be said,
and it was not hiding behind something. I did this, but you know what I mean?
There was always that feeling that I have whenever I see some people
apologizing. Yeah. For things that they did is like, I'm sorry,
but you hit me first. I'm sorry. But you thought, you know what I mean? No,
if you to say, sorry, say you, sorry,
there was a whole explanation because just saying, sorry. Wouldn't when,
when it suffice, but like what you said in the beginning is really what bother,
what usually bothers me is using your,
your path to shield from away from saying that you
actually take ownership of what you did or, or apologize. I mean,
I think I said most of it in the first video. I mean, I was,
I was operating off limited information,
but I felt like I understood what was going on and this confirmed it for me
guys. I don't know how many times I can tell you this.
I promise you there's gonna be a cost.
So my only advice is what I said before cash out. I know it's hard to, to, to,
to, to hear that because you're like, I haven't done it,
but so how you gonna tell me to,
and it's hard for me to tell you the grass of greener on this side,
but it's really not. And um,
I don't want to see you guys suffer for playing in the wrong
playground. You feel me? So don't just don't do it.
Was he in the wrong playground though? Cause when he,
as soon as he realized he was on the wrong playground. Okay. Okay.
As soon as he realized he was on, I'll explain. Okay. At my school,
they got a yard, right? We got a giant yard.
They got a giant fence around the yard word, right. The fence. Right.
And people in the yard, high schoolers, everyone knows what time it is.
If you're 30 years old and you're inside the yard, it looks odd.
If you're 30 years old and you're right outside the fence, it's not illegal.
Looks odd. What you're looking at. It don't hang around the fence.
But if you realize that you're around the fence and you leave,
you were still around the fence,
but you were just seen around the fence too many times,
you were seen around the fence. You know what I mean?
Like if I'm a teacher and I see familiar with a hoodie,
hang around the fence and I seen him five times, he didn't do anything.
He didn't do anything. But I'm calling the cops.
<laugh> cause som about to get abducted. Yeah. Yo Sandy, come inside.
You don't want you to it taken, you feel me, you know, we, you, Hey,
where's the pretty blonde girl at. She's definitely taking you.
Let's go get in here. You feel me? So that's what it came down to.
Don't don't be hanging around the fence. Like it's,
it's like even the idea of impropriety is enough to
be condemned. Yeah. You don't actually have to have done any feel me. Yeah.
You hang around with hooligan long enough, guilty by association.
You know what I mean? You gotta, you gotta like, like it's a, like a vampire,
just do a cross, throw some oil, rub some garlic everywhere. Walk away,
throw some oil. Yeah. Yeah. Holy water. I don't know. <laugh> listen.
It is what you played dungeon and dragon. You should know oil. Yeah. I mean,
if you, if you throw some oil, you sit on fire. I mean, garlic, no,
that's not gonna do nothing. Except the garlic oil. Anyways,
it's all this to say. <laugh> just, don't do it. Just don't do it. And um,
as far as Chris goes, hopefully, you know,
miss Korea takes off and goes right back to what it was.
And if it doesn't that's okay. Um, as long as he gets help,
I need needs to deal with that issue.
I actually think it's better for him to have gone through all this and to deal
with his problems rather than he keep going down the path that he was going.
Cuz that path that he was going was, was gonna be a way worse ending.
I, through this kind of time away,
I've Seeked out a lot of, kind of, you know, medical advice,
therapy and stuff like that. Uh, that doesn't.
Matter here nor there. I appreciate it. You didn't go more into details of,
I went into therapy and this and that and it helped me.
And I realized because it doesn't matter.
And oftentimes when people do something wrong, they're gonna go into the,
you know, I did therapy and it was wrong.
And they talk about the process of the therapy. It doesn't matter.
It doesn't when it doesn't of really matter about what you did,
we don't need to go into the details or maybe it is just me being,
you know, when we have, when we see conversation and we're like,
we feel like we're,
we're outta place hearing that you and the details of what happened in your,
in your process. I don't feel like I'm,
I have to know everything about that. That is your business.
And it has nothing to do with your apology or whatever. Just,
you know, say, you're sorry. That's if you, if you did something wrong,
if you did something, if you feel like you did something wrong,
but I appreciate that he didn't go into the details and that,
because it doesn't really matter. And I,
I agree that it doesn't matter if you do something wrong or by your stance are
wrong, then what you to rectify that, or maybe why,
what you'd be doing your absence is relevant information to the discussion.
As long as you're not using it to shield yourself from any culpability.
I think admitting the fact that you're going to therapy is a good thing.
And I think one thing that we have as a taboo, as a,
as a country is that we don't like to talk about the mental health stuff now.
Sure. You see what people hide by that to not accept responsibility?
I just put you put, you just put your finger on it.
What bothers me is exactly what the you said is that people shield themselves
behind it. It's not so much that you talk about it cuz he did talk about it.
That's not what I have a problem about it. I don't have a problem. I don't want,
but what you, what you just said, what bothers me is the shielding behind it.
Yeah, but I, I think there could be two separate things. You could have a,
a mental health issue. Yes.
Or you could have some kind of addiction or whatever doesn't bother me. Right?
You could be seeking therapy.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and it also still means that you still have some r
esponsibility for what you did. Fine. You know, those two things can go exist.
And I don't think it's good that we encourage people not to talk about the fact
that they're going to therapy or whatever.
Cuz I think more people do need to talk about that. It's not what I meant.
It's exactly what you said more bothers me is people shielding themselves behind
that, sir. And not picking accountability.
And.